i got an email from taylor but i've
asked i got a bunch of emails on this
question
which is how do i find a good therapist
what are the red flags that i should
look for
i typed up some notes here just thinking
through
um what people should look for in a
counselor why counseling all that so
i want to run through a couple of these
real quick and if you have more
questions about
seeing a counselor am i seeing the right
one what is the
best modality what are things you like
all that kind of stuff shoot me an email
at ask john ramseysolutions.com and i'll
continue to dig into this
one of my dreams here that we're working
on as we speak
is building a network of preferred
counselors throughout the country both
in person and digital and via
like zoom or skype and so
i want to know what you're thinking
about counselors good experiences bad
experiences
let me know everything you've
experienced with counseling again at
askjohn
ramseysolutions.com just put in the
headline experience with
with counselors or questions about
therapists that that would help
help us as we begin to to build out this
network
so here's the deal what is counseling
at the end of the day counseling is just
a professional
helping relationship that's it like you
go see a plumber
for professional help with plumbing a
counselor is or a therapist or a
psychologist
you used to be psychiatrists most
psychiatrists now are medical
or medicine dispensers there are still
some great ones left there
but they are professional helpers
marriage and family therapists clinical
social workers
a good counselor is not your friend
they are not your buddy they are not a
future romantic partner
and their job is not always to make you
feel good
hear me say that counseling will be
uncomfortable if it's done right
it will challenge you if it's done right
a counselor's job is to walk alongside
you
and help gently point you to other
directions
that you may not have considered walking
in because whatever is working
not working in your life could be better
on the other side of a different road of
a different avenue on a different bridge
whatever that may look like
they help you see challenges that you
might have missed or that you are
avoiding another thing a counselor does
they reflect back to you
the way they experience you in a session
this is often how you interact with the
outside world one of my favorite
therapy instructors ever is irving yalam
and he talks about
everything in a session is data and so
if i find myself as a counselor after
the session three and you start talking
and i'm like oh my gosh this is getting
boring
that's an important moment for a
therapist to reflect back do you bore
the people
in your life is it hard for people to be
around you
do they get frustrated with you because
you talk low and low energy and you kind
of are
you bring a room down right so
everything is data so a counselor is
going to reflect back to you
or do you bring sexual energy to
everything do you bring this
fake excitement to everything do you
talk so so so much
a counselor is going to reflect back to
you the way they experience you in a
session
and that's going to leave me the next
thing they should then teach you new
skills on how to relate to the outside
world
because most everything every
challenge you have mental health
challenges
personal challenges personal development
issues
problems at work problems with bosses
come back to broken or hurting or
fractured relationships
and so a good counselor is going to
teach you how to interact in
relationship teach you how to interact
with the outside world
as a series of steps a counselor should
also call you on your bs
when they're teaching you these skills
right they should tell you that's not
factual that's not how that works they
should you should have a good enough
rapport that you trust them enough to be
honest with you
if you cannot hear honest feedback let
your counselor know that
and they'll they'll work with you i
subscribe to terry real's idea
um he's one of the most extraordinary uh
relationship
therapists in the world that a counselor
should not always be neutral
they should tell you the truth if you're
going with a couple the counselor should
be able to say
hey husband you're being an idiot right
now hey wife
you are using a one-down position to
drag use your power
to drag down this whole relationship
into a land mines right
i do think there's moments when
counselors should not be neutral and
they should tell
you the truth and lean in against you if
they need to
here's some important things about
counseling go three or four
sessions before you bail don't just go
one and be like i don't like them
they're weird they're annoying
don't go two and say nothing's happening
yet don't just stop going session three
and four
is often when things start to turn when
things start to click
when should you go to counseling i
recommend that everyone can benefit from
a neutral third party in their life
i just think they can a mentor a guide
someone that you totally trust who will
help you
someone you can be totally vulnerable
with this could be a counselor a mentor
a support group
like i said counselors are professionals
right if i've got a plumbing issue
i've got some buddies that know how to
do some some minor plumbing they can
come help me
put in a sprinkler line or something if
i need to fix my sewer main
i'm going to call a professional i don't
want to deal with it i'm going to pay
the money i'm going to get the warranty
on it
that's what i'm talking about going to
see a counselor if you're struggling
with like hey my wife and i had a fight
last night
um man call you call somebody that you
trust go have coffee i'll process it out
and through a trustworthy good friend
you can be vulnerable with man have that
conversation
if it's deeper than that call call a
professional
one of my mentors dr aretha marbley and
dr brett hendricks
two important people in my life said
that most people wait to go to
counseling until there's a crisis
don't wait until the house is on fire
before you go check things out
one one of them suggested most people
wait to go to counseling until there's a
crisis is similar to
waiting till you have the flu to start a
workout program right that's the worst
time
if things are going pretty good that's a
good time when you're healthy you're
feeling right go see somebody then
right i think everyone thinking about
getting married or having a long-term
partnership with somebody should engage
in counseling just having somebody else
talk about questions that you haven't
even thought about
yet if you have major trauma that you're
having trouble processing
go see somebody not everyone who has a
tragedy needs a therapist i hear that
all the time hey my son or daughter had
somebody die
in their classroom in middle school i
need to get into a counselor right not
necessarily
not necessarily one of the rules of
trauma response is
most people don't need you most of the
time when they're talking about a crisis
responder or a therapist
but sometimes they do if you find
yourself unable to sleep
unable to grieve you find yourself
withdrawing and alone you realize that
netflix is much more likely
you're much more likely to hang out with
netflix than you are with the people
that you love
um a counselor could be a great blessing
there things to watch out for
you should not be in counseling forever
a counselor's job is to walk alongside
you
help you and send you on your way both
folks that i have met with for
any length of time the first thing they
told me in the session was my job is to
work myself out of a job with you and
that's how i knew
i got the right person i got the right
person there i am a
big believer outside of you have to do
this for insurance purposes and that's a
whole other conversation we can have
someday
i don't like diagnosis in the first
session they don't know you they haven't
experienced you
i don't even like them in the first few
sessions because that's what presents as
a quote unquote diagnosis
tends to be an ecosystem issue it tends
to be a giant process issue
outside of a very few like bipolar
disorder
or schizophrenia or major depressive
disorder some of these big ones
if they are a jerk walk out the door
counseling is about the relationship
period right if you aren't gelling after
three or four sessions
let them know hey this relationship
isn't working for me they should have
big boy girl and pants and say cool
thank you for letting me know and then
go find somebody else right
a trained therapist should not ask you
to dig into the details of your trauma
in the first session either you should
work into that over several sessions
after you two have discussed a safety
plan how you will cope etc
last thing is where do you find a
counselor they're everywhere they're
online local college towns have interns
ask a friend churches often have free
counselors
um the community counseling centers have
free or low-cost individual family
counseling
and then there's just websites in your
local community
there are i don't know like uh referrals
for
yelp and i mean their counselors are
everywhere particularly since covet
since covet launched um there have been
way more counselors who put their
practices online and really have have
people in rural communities can see
therapists now it's just kind of spread
out so
that's some thoughts on counseling how
to find a therapist what's a good
therapist when to leave therapy
if you've got more questions again email
me at askjohn ramseysolutions.com